Und wieder gibt es zweifel an der dunkle materie in
65 millionen lichtjahren entfernung wurde einen zwerg galaxie gefunden die sich komplett anders verhält als alle anderen bisher gefundenen galaxien
sie enthält nämlich keine
Beziehungsweise trauben dunkle materie wenn es sie denn gäbe also
wieder ein gegenbeweis der dunkle materie und warum jetzt diejenigen die eine andere theorie
Als die dunkle materie für die bewegung der galaxien haben probleme haben also dass. Jetzt alles bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ngc
Tf2 das ist der name der seltsamen zwerggalaxien eigentlich eine ganz normale galaxie aber mit einer besonderheit
Im vergleich zum beispiel zu unserer milchstraße enthält sie
250 mal weniger sterne eine ganz besondere klasse von galaxien diese klasse ist durchsichtig man
Sieht die galaxien dahinter sie gehört zur klasse der ultra diffusen galaxien die überhaupt erst vor wenigen jahren entdeckt wurde zitat ich
Habe eine stunde lang nur auf dieses bild gstaad das sagt pieter van dokkum von der yale university
Er hatte die galaxien eine aufnahme, des hubble weltraumteleskops entdeckt und da wurde pieter van dokkum
neugierig sein forschungsteam untersuchte 10 kugelsternhaufen der galaxien er und stellte
verblüffendes fest anders als bei allen anderen galaxien waren die bewegungen dieser sternenhaufen komplett durch die vorhandene materie
Zu erklären sprich dort gibt es keine oder nur sehr wenig dunkle materie maximal können sie ein vier
hundertstel der materie in der galaxie seien bei 300 millionen sonnenmassen ist das weniger als eine million sonnenmasse
Absolut lächerlich und dem kosmologischen standardmodell zuwider laufen dementsprechend es rund
27% dunkle materie neben der noch angenommen 70 prozent dunkler energie sein müssten da die sichtbare materie
Im standardmodell nur drei prozent ausmacht dürften es nicht ein 400 zu sein also
025 sondern im vergleich zur normalen materie
1000 also das 4000 fache
Dass es wirklich absolut verrückt hier stimmt einfach etwas überhaupt gar nicht zitat eine galaxie ohne dunkle materie
Kommt wo uns völlig überraschend sie ist eigentlich der wichtigste teil jeder galaxie
Der diese zusammenhält sagt stellt alle gängigen theorien auf den prüfstand
Meint van dokkum bisher galt es als sicher dass
dunkle materie überhaupt erst die entstehung von galaxien ermöglicht erst sie soll die
sichtbare materie anziehen und zur verklumpung, zu sternen und planeten führen aber
ngc 10 52 - df 2 zeigt das gegenteil
demnach würde diese theorie gar nicht stimmen und noch eine andere schwierigkeit gibt es und zwar für
Diejenigen die das universum ohne dunkle materie erklären wollen obst wenn diese galaxie die sich komplett anders verhält
Dann, dann ist es unmöglich ein neues modell der gravitation ohne dunkle materie. Zu entwickeln es würde in dieser galaxie
einfach nicht funktionieren
Jetzt sucht das forschungsteam nach
weiteren galaxien ohne dunkle materie und bis dahin bleiben nur spekulationen denn diese zwerggalaxien ist auch in anderer hinsicht
Seltsam keine galaxie name kein richtiges zentrum und jetzt kommt es kein super
massereiches schwarzes loch
Im zentrum das alles führt mich ja zurück zur theorie der schwarzen löcher als der dunkle materie
erinnert euch die beschreibung von dunkler materie und
schwarzen löchern ist nahezu gleich nur dass wir schwarze löcher kennen die theorie der schwarzen löcher
also
Als dunkle materie ist ja das alles voller schwarzer löcher ist auch sie können wir nicht sehen auch sie
Könnten den größten teil der materie ausmachen und eine solche galaxie ist ja das absolut den dienst dafür die sterne sind hier so weit entfernt
dass sie nur wenige und nur kleinere schwarze löcher bilden konnten nicht mal ein super massereiches schwarzes loch
Im zentrum gibt es passt also alles eigentlich an genau zu dieser theorie
Ich bin mega gespannt was wir alles noch zur dunklen materie in der nächsten zeit kommt
Ich finde es unglaublich spannend wenn er als erstes neues zu dunkle materie
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp
das geht hier dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen an land vom neuesten video garantiert und zur begrüßung
Gibt es übrigens darauf whatsapp noch ein gratis gudi also seid gespannt einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit glocke verkehr
Also, mit glock genau hier geht es weiter sie dafür auch draufklicken
Dunkle materie rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle da geht es genau. Um diese theorie also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran